zur metapher
münchen meine lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen hier zum dienstag wo ich
immer einen einzelnen kommunen vorstelle
und es sieht mégane eis aus guck mal
hier so einen fluss der so geteilt wird
und dann sind hier so berge und und hey
du sagte immer der titel cool der ich
doch gar nicht so cool an alle leute die
den eventuell doch haben wollen da ist
das lied und wir fangen natürlich direkt
an mit dem komma hat heute am dienstag
wo ich immer kurz vorstellte die ein
bisschen umfangreicher sind bzw sachen
dazufügen wo man ein bisschen länger
drüber reden kann und zwar geben wir
erstmal einen / giff et also für mich
oder halt auch im namen der eingeben
command unterstrich block dann bekommen
wir ein command blog da nehme ich mir
auch genossen hebel und setzte das hin
und dann finde ich dort diesem command
einsätze den hebel daneben und bevor ich
auf aktivieren drücke es ist ein command
von minecraft befindet ihnen der
bestattung verlinkte findet den
commander der beschreibung verlinkt ihr
findet das video dazu einbringen
und ja das war es glaube ich dazu hat
noch sonst wie mein equipment oder meine
sozialen netzwerk dass interessierte ja
kein schwein deswegen fangen wir direkt
an hier mitten drauf drücken und wir
sehen schon wenn der da oben den red hot
dog erreicht hat geht die maschine
kreiert und wir können hier gleich ganz
simpel wenn ihr unten links im chat des
maschinist vorbild können wir hier
draufklicken right click in dessen zuge
die items ticken wir richtig drauf und
wir sehen schon die bekommen ein kessel
eine netter stellen und einen router
switches ruhe in nahost eine kollegin zu
getty pandoras box frohwitter scarlett
die box to open das ziel also ziel so
verriegelung oder sowas ventures break
that of the box 2 unleashed disaster in
the world also mit so was wie der deckel
von etwa sage ich mal
um das mal ganz kurz übersetzten also
wir haben einen kessel einen never stern
und einen ritter skelett schädel um das
mal zeigen falls sie das jetzt gerade
nicht so ganz verstanden hat was damit
gemeint ist wir setzen das mal dahin und
schmeißen dort einen nenner stern rein
und dass es pandoras box ich habe mal
die pandoras box mod vorgestellt das
verlinke ich euch mal wenn ihr das
gerade seht da hab ich das irgendwo
verlinkt wenn ihr wollt oder da ich
irgendwie könnte auf jeden fall gern mal
drauf klicken wenn ihr euch die mod dazu
anschauen wollt natürlich hatte die
mutter noch eigene texturen und so
weiter und auch alles viel puder und
hatte mir eigenschaft und was alles aber
dass sie es mit einem command gemachten
wandel am ein kraft- und das ist auf
jeden fall dafür auch schon egal
und zwar kann ich dann hier einfach auf
diese pandoras box box box boxee box ich
kann noch einen theoretisch drauf schlag
ich bin ja gerade creative mond das
heißt es müsste eigentlich kaputt gehen
geht es allerdings nicht da es
verschlossen ist mit diesem lied und
verstand noch mal im chat um das ganze
zu öffnen müssen wir ganz einfach ihr
einen withers klatsche gegen schweiß und
jetzt das ganze fängt jetzt ein bisschen
an zu blumen an den seiten das bringt
allerdings noch nichts deswegen wir
müssen erst dagegen fliegen und müssen
das einmal jetzt können das ganze zu
erstellen wenn wir hier drauf geschäft
zerstören
ein cop noch glatt es kommt es kommt
doch ein gast hat ihr seht schott es
bauen sich über rechts hoch und meine
ganze welt versetzt sich in übel und
krankheit und unheil und was plötzlich
das ganze passiert hier und wird
generiert und zwar ich weiß nicht ob es
kratzer klettern aber die pandoras box
ist eine box die es damals in der
griechischen mythologie gab die wenn man
sie öffnet komplettes unheil und übel
und krankheiten oder die welt hat
generieren lassen sagt ich mache ja und
das passiert ja jetzt gerade also diese
roten never rag teil kommt aus der hölle
und stehen so ein bisschen dafür so ja
auch wir sind unheil blabla da vorne
fängt alles an zu brennen
hier brennt auch was unter ganz hinten
genau da hinten brennt auch etwas die
fliegen die ganze gas geben wir sehen
die runden zombies und wenn ich dort
rein theoretisch mal im survival mode
reingeht der an wen ich ein bisschen
schwierig sagen also man muss sich da
wenn man die in survival mode öffnet
echt schon krass vorbereiten also
wirklich mit gold äpfel mit diamant
rüstung mit jemand schwerter mit
entscheidenden sachen und so weiter und
das ist jetzt quasi alles was dieser
command hinzufügt und zwar diese ganzen
sachen werden hier quasi generiert und
stehen so ein bisschen für unheil und
alles möglich und wirklich wenn ich im
survival mode wär würd ich halt
einerseits von denen da angegriffen
werden von diesem gas hier oben der
denkt sich sky select hier oder wie hoch
fliegt er da oben denn bitte geht ist
ein richtiges flugzeug du mann mann mann
du kleiner mann kommen auf den boden der
tatsachen zurück allerdings ist das
natürlich noch nicht alles und zwar ist
hier natürlich jetzt der coach und man
denkt sich erstmal er steht ja immer
noch hier das heißt wenn ich dir noch
mal öffnet was passiert dann
da passiert nämlich nix man bekommt
nämlich nur ein hotel und ein risiko ist
es da
da ist es nicht was haben wir denn das
wollen wir dann wo hammer ego ist es
okay der lack hat noch von secured alter
aber mir ist gerade selber danach
aufgefallen nach der szenen dass sich
united ist das scheißegal weil jedes
item was im umkreis von diesem hobby dem
lied ist secured das heißt wenn man
beispielsweise diese pandoras box öffnet
und dann ist ja quasi offen
und dann kommt der ganze scheiß
ausländer schließlich wieder macht man
das wieder offen
bekommt man dieses hobby und zwar wenn
ich das hin schmeiße jetzt haltet euch
fest im 5 blog radius ich glaub ich hab
sie aufgenommen
das sieht man hier ganz gut und zwar
dort hier da noch da fünf blöcke nach
davonflog uns weiter alle items die in
dem umkreis liegen das heißt wenn ich da
man kessel den schmeißen oder da noch
ein kessel und da noch ein knochen und
da noch ein knochen und da noch ein
pfeil über jedem item steht sie keyword
außer über diesen nenner stern behauptet
übersteht und zwar egal was ich damit
jetzt mache ich könnte dort rein
theoretisch mal tnt hinsetzen in die
direkt in die nähe und zwar wenn tnt
einsätze würden ja eigentlich so dass
alten da geht auf jeden fall kaputt
allerdings schon
das hat ein bisschen lang gedauert die
explosionen oder wir schon die items die
im umkreis liegend gehen nicht kaputt
und zwar steht dort rüber ja auch secure
das heißt dieses hoch weiter macht
einerseits wenn ich nicht mehr hier den
unfallstelle
seht ihr schon nicht bekomme direkt
heilung sättigung den ganzen steht also
das ist mir auf jeden fall gut geht und
wenn die alten sie drum rum liegen die
sind secure das heißt die können jetzt
nicht kaputt gehen ich kann es euch noch
mal demonstrieren weil die neuen items
jetzt ja auch dazu gekommen sind also
revel et cetera pp
diese sind jetzt halt auch in diesem
blog radius und dementsprechend ist auch
hier der kreml immer noch secured die da
vorne allerdings nicht das heißt wenn
ich hier vorne mal in tnt hinsetzen
würde
die würden ganz normal mich das
explodieren lassen würde kaputtgehen
seien allerdings müssen durch zu zeigen
weil das natürlich wieder neue items
sind kommt durch die explosion
allerdings geht nichts kaputt und wenn
ich dann jedoch dieses hob altem
wegnehme dann sind die wieder beschädigt
mit beschädigten beschädigt war und dann
seht ihr schon wenn das hinterher
explodiert wo die teams gehen auch davon
also der fall beispielsweise wenn wir
der wahl der fall aufgesammelt aber der
rest ist auf jeden fall disappear
schauen was passiert wenn ich ein schaf
in die luft explodieren lassen
und damit es dort aber wieder ganz viele
neue team auch gleich gleich kommt
wieder jemand in die kommentare der sich
in letzter zeit immer der heiß als
youtube user scharf und her kommt hier
dann soll der held aber naja ich glaube
ihr wisst was ich meine
mit pandoras box beziehung mit diesem
hobby das bekommt man wenn man die
pandoras box nachdem sie geöffnet wurde
wieder verschlossen war wieder eröffnet
und wenn man die ganze scheiße hier im
survival mode öffnet müsste man sich auf
jeden fall super vorbereiten
allerdings wenn man sich dann denken
keinen bock mehr auf den ganzen steht
kann man hier draufklicken right click
bis sein to destroy die maschinen und
dann seht ihr schon die maschine geht
weg und wenn ich jetzt dass hopper
hinschmeißen verliert das ganze seine
wirkung das heißt wenn ich mag es neben
schmeißt und so geht wenn ich dann
hinsetzen das kaputt ihr seht schon ich
habe keine direkt heilung oder so und
jeden moment liegt dann auch dieses auf
altem in die luft und ihr seht schon
wir haben leider kein hoppla mehr da
freunde das was heute mit dem command
mal ein bisschen kürzer gehalten also
ich hab euch die sachen jetzt nicht so
umfangreich vorgestellt also das was ich
hab's euch schon vorgestellt wie es halt
in dem komma drin ist aber ich habe so
viel darum gelabert wie ich das mache
die ganzen mops et cetera sind weg
dementsprechend würde ich sagen
verabschiede ich mich auch mal von euch
wenn es euch gefallen dann will ich mich
über eine wertung freuen oder ein
abonnement oder sonst was wenn ihr mehr
command sehen wollt die kommen immer
dienstags kommt ein großer command und
freitags kommt immer einen sonnen sonnen
dings command also 3,2 sie vorgestellt
und drei kleinere und dann wünscht euch
noch einen schönen tag